lots of people are still reacting to
bachelor colton
underwood coming out of the closet
yesterday on good morning america
cassie randolph hasn't said anything
publicly yet but one of the runner-ups
from colton's season has spoken out
tasha adams was on clickbait with
bachelor nation and she says
she isn't upset with colton
i was a little shocked at first
but all in all the happiness that i have
for him that he's finally able to live
his truth
and to be out and like the sense of
relief that i got from his interview
is something that i have to commend
immensely and i'm just so happy that
he's able to
just be him i don't feel like i wasted
my time
mm-hmm yeah i really do not i feel like
i learned so much about myself
in that own journey and i really did try
to give myself the opportunity to see
colton in my future and the thing is
like it worked out the way it was
supposed to like it didn't
it wasn't me and it wasn't met in the
cards
it wasn't in the cards for us and i
think that with him
breaking up with hannah g and i we
didn't understand at the time
but he was struggling with that and the
fact that he had to pray
he thanked god the day that he became
bachelor saying like thank you for
allowing me to be straight
is so sad to me like he knew
yes he knew
uh yeah now uh billy eichner posted this
clip when he made an appearance on
colton's season of the bachelor that
ended up
being very true
i'm gay i know that's a shock colton and
that i think
you should look into maybe you're the
first gay bachelor and we don't even
know
[Music]
put that in your promo see you later
okay so colton actually commented on
that instagram post so colton wrote
love you love this now and now i love
being gay
and billy responded i'm happy for you
see you at the club colton
billy also wrote about colton's coming
out two things
number one pop culture now sometimes
makes it seem like every 14 year old gay
boy is flying out of the closet without
a care in the world
some are and that's incredible but many
are not so let's remember that
and let's also honor and praise those in
entertainment who came out
years decades before it was embraced and
could be used to professional advantage
i don't mean me i mean many others
especially those before me
that took real guts let's put some shine
on them too
yeah and then in another tweet uh he
said uh here's how hollywood works
colton's gonna get a glad award before i
do
as the tony says good for him it's hard
to live your truth in the world
ali says colton looks caught in
headlights uh
on that clip joyce says this is a show
about finding fame i'm not loved yeah
uh keisha me and ross talked about
yesterday yeah what was your reaction to
colton
coming out oh yeah being okay with it
uh my reaction to colton coming out i
wasn't surprised i had met him in person
i did an interview
and i remember when he left saying to
the producers
i don't think he's straight there's no
way because there were a lot of moments
where you could just tell
it was even off camera i just felt like
there was no way that he was straight
and
then i felt bad i was like oh i'm
watching the show and i had this thought
and then i thought maybe i'm tripping
so i'm not surprised uh i like tasha's
response i thought it was
very respectful and eloquent and i think
at the end of the day
you know everyone deserves peace this
took a lot of courage
it pained me to hear it in his voice the
way he was gulping and breathing i was
like oh my god no one should ever have
to live like that
and the bachelor is a huge show with
very passionate fans and i'm sure
he was concerned on how bachelor nation
was going to react
and then otherwise i think that he does
owe the women
individual apologies or at least
acknowledgements
um i'm concerned for cassie you know
cassie was granted a restraining order
for harassment stalking i know that
order was later
dropped but i'm sure this is not fun for
her either and she's gone through a lot
of things because he's going through his
own internal struggle and she was a
little bit um the residual effects of
that so
you know i i worry for cassie i'm i'm
proud of colton for coming out i hope
that he heals himself but i also hope he
heals
people that maybe he might have heard
along the way as much as he can
yeah and i i a lot of the talk now
you know comes well why don't they they
they do finally
a gay bachelor because we've talked a
whole lot about this and how you got to
do something with this franchise uh but
here's the great part
is that colton is no longer under
bachelor contract
he's now under netflix contract and
they're doing that docu series about his
coming out so this could actually be a
move
for netflix to grab a bachelor
star and be the first people to do a
sort of
pseudo gay version of the bachelor on
their platform
and just completely take it all all out
from underneath
the uh underneath the bachelor which
would be which would be incredible
if he goes from being the first closeted
gay bachelor to the first bachelor to
come
out of the closet to then be the first
bachelor on the gay bachelor or possibly
the first gay host of the gay bachelor
like there's so many ways that this
thing
could go and you have to understand that
every single person
is looking at what possibilities are out
there for this
right yeah we asked netflix about that
yeah they're not commenting or
confirming that report yet yeah they're
doing a series with um uh with colton
comfort says good for him he still
doesn't it still doesn't change the fact
that people
aren't over suddenly having a memorable
loss that he was a stalker
yeah you brought that up uh with cassie
so tony says this keisha and i think
tony is a black man by his
thumbnail he says hate to say it but
black women can tell a lot faster if a
guy is gay do you think that's true
oh i didn't know that the gaydar changed
honey i had no idea um i'll take it
i'll take it yeah i can tell i mean yeah
i can tell i feel like for the most part
you can tell
you know sometimes it's a little bit
questionable you're like yeah maybe i'm
tripping
but yeah no i could feel it maybe he's
right i'm gonna just take it so
we'll just take it somebody else who
another another friend of mine who's gay
said that he knew years ago that colton
underwood was gay for the simple fact
that he follows channing tatum on
instagram
how does he
he's like he's like straight straight
guys don't follow channing tatum on
instagram
interesting i will say like the
the tasha response is like i mean
tasha's
experience with coleman was on a reality
tv show so i don't think she was
necessarily
completely hurt by that circumstance
like i even saw an article saying
uh colton's ex tasha adams responds like
x is a strong word i mean they had an
interaction on a
tv show so yeah i think like but i
appreciate that tasha is okay
with yeah that circumstance but i don't
think she had any like lingerie feelings
because it was on a reality tv show
i honestly like i don't love billy
eichner's responses to this and it's
kind of what i'm seeing in the gay
community a little bit like
it's the idea of yeah i knew colton was
gay but kind of taking credit for that
and
taking ownership over like i find that
i've seen gaming being a little
egotistical
egotistical and making it about
themselves saying oh i knew he was gay
this is a surprise to me
like i'm not loving that response i
don't love
billy's uh tweets either i'm not sure
what he's getting at like even when he
says
um you know we want to praise the people
that came out years ago before was in
brazil could be used to professional
advantage is he saying that
colton is going to use this for
professional advantage like i don't love
that tweet
i don't love the tweet versus colton's
going to get a glad award before me like
billy agner is suddenly making it about
him when shouldn't he just applaud that
someone's coming out of the closet so i
don't love them seeing that kind of
reaction from the gay community this
trying to make it about me and how i
knew for years and this
so yeah i don't love that response i
just wish people would be more embracing
of colton but
that's a stereotype of the gay community
that they start coming after each other
so i'm not loving that response in that
aspect to colton coming out
and also there's a there's an aspect i i
agree
there's also an aspect of this that
people just love to be right
everybody just like to say called it
right everybody loves first
right everybody everybody loves that
me too that was me i was like
did you hear i said ain't a surprise
honey i already knew
you know see everybody at first